[Music]
the comedian w kamau bell is uh one of
those interesting sorts of comedians who
has made the bold choice to never be
funny like so many other comedians today
bell calls himself a comedian and yet
has never made anyone laugh ever in his
life he's never been involved in a funny
joke unless his career itself is the
joke in fact bell is so relentlessly
unfunny and uninteresting that he
received the most damning professional
indictment imaginable which is a show on
cnn he's the host of united shades of
america where he preaches about race
i assume i haven't seen it and neither
has anybody else so we can only
speculate
bell was also hired as a spokesman for
something called the abortion access
fund where he produced a father's day
psa encouraging men to celebrate
father's day by supporting women
by becoming a pro-abortion feminist
because that's how you support women
he says now
we'll play the thing in a minute but and
this is not my main objection that i
would raise to this psa uh we'll get to
those in a moment but
we should note how this is yet another
father's day message that isn't really
for or about fathers
for whatever reason we're not allowed to
simply just celebrate fathers in this
country all of the marketing and
messaging around mother's day is about
how wonderful mothers are but for
father's day we talk about the things
that fathers are doing wrong
father's day is mostly an afterthought
like a participation trophy we give to
dads after all the over-the-top
festivities for mother's day and when it
is acknowledged it's usually to lecture
men about their failures
so we give fathers the gift of nagging
for father's day as if they didn't
already have an endless supply of that
readily on hand but that's neither here
nor there as the problem with this
pro-abortion father's day message goes
way beyond the issues i just raised
see you for yourself check it out
dad does so much for the family this
father's day give him what he really
needs
not a home brewing kit not socks
give him safe and legal access to
abortion
hello i'm noted male feminist w kamal
bell do you know how much i've spent on
birth control in my life
213 dollars mostly on condoms that
expire to my wallet you know how much my
wife has spent
17
530 dollars
dads if you've ever had sex and not had
a kid it's likely birth control or
abortion played a role okay we have to
stop it already because bell has proven
that he can't talk about issues related
to the female body without descending
into these amateurish misconceptions in
about 40 seconds the left you know
because they have no other rebuttal they
like to accuse pro-life men of being
sexless in cells who don't know anything
about women i've always found this
charge interesting given that i have a
wife and four children but it turns out
not surprisingly that pro-abortion men
are the ones who understand very little
about the female body
um the ones who who've actually enjoyed
the company of a woman
because they they managed to find one
with low enough standards to accommodate
them seem to view birth control and
abortion as magical elixirs that simply
make
babies and thus their responsibilities
simply disappear they imagine apparently
that without birth control
a baby would materialize after every
sexual encounter
that's why bell says that if a man has
ever had sex and not had a baby it's
because of birth control or abortion
what he doesn't seem to understand is
that
women are not uh fertile every day of
the month in fact they aren't fertile
most days of the month a woman's body
works in cycles and she's only capable
of conceiving a child for a certain
short period during that cycle usually
about six days which means that
most of the times you've had sex and not
had a baby it has nothing to do with
birth control or abortion in fact there
are couples if you can believe it who
don't use birth control at all and have
sex frequently and don't end up with 900
kids
that's not a miracle of science it's
just science
and you might want to learn a thing or
two about it before recording another
psa on the subject
let's continue
we're used to not having to worry about
it but nobody ever got pregnant from a
vibrator for that you need
that's right see the majority of people
seeking abortions are already parents
they know it's right for their families
they would know if having another kid
would send them spiraling into poverty
it definitely would
oh my god
funny you should mention god because
there's literally no mention of the word
abortion in here just like in here
there's no mention of how the state is
going to help these families if they
forced to bear these children it's
almost like this is just a way for a few
fragile men to use religion to control
our bodies
[Music]
so remember the rule here if somebody is
bringing up religion in the context of
the abortion debate
it's almost always going to be a leftist
in this case bell puts pulls out the
bible to make the case for abortion and
then the next sentence accuses
pro-lifers of doing the same he says
that abortion is never mentioned in the
bible except that it is plain as day
right in the ten commandments thou shalt
not kill is the injunction quite
famously
actually correctly translated the
commandment is to quote do no murder and
this is how jesus quotes the passage in
matthew 19 18 do no murder thou shalt
not murder there are of course many
different forms of murder and many
different ways that people are murdered
and the bible doesn't bother itself with
listing every single potential version
of the crime because there's no need to
if you're killing an innocent and
defenseless human being
you are committing murder and therefore
running a foul of god's commandment
abortion kills an innocent and
defenseless human being and so it is
murder
therefore abortion is mentioned in the
bible now this is not how i would choose
to argue my case if i'm talking to a
secular person
my first point would not be that the
bible forbids it but since he brought it
up
i feel the need to correct the record
um speaking of things that aren't
mentioned in places do you do you know
what you know what uh the bill of rights
never mentions
abortion in fact it never mentions
abortion or anything related to abortion
or anything that could be remotely
interpreted as having something to do
with abortion
the word abortion never appears anywhere
in the constitution
abortion is not a constitutional right
but rather a right invented by nine
people in robes in 1973
all of those people by the way were men
all right now for some reason we're
going to continue watching this so let's
keep going
daddy's doing a psa
okay
ask any parent parenting is a job a
wonderful very difficult job
and since when does america force
anybody to do a job against their will
without paying them by controlling their
bodies
oh yeah right
so as we celebrate father's day let's
also celebrate birth control abortion
and bodily autonomy because many we
benefited from those
so enjoy your day guys and welcome to
the fight we've been waiting for you
[Music]
parenting is a difficult job he says
which is why parents should have the
option to kill their children instead
and this is the argument the man is
making
while holding his own daughter
it's almost as if pro-abortion activists
are soulless psychopaths i don't know he
also draws a parallel between the
pro-life position and slavery claiming
that we enslave women
by quote forcing them to do a job
against their will the problem with this
comparison is that
being a parent is not merely a job okay
any more than being a son or a daughter
is merely a job parent describes a
natural biological relationship this is
my whole argument for why you shouldn't
call yourself the parent of your dog
slavery on the other hand describes an
unnatural oppressive man-made construct
if you're a parent it means that you
have conceived a human being
and that alone makes you a parent by
definition
the job part describes the legal and
moral responsibilities that come with
this relationship slaves have no natural
responsibility to their owners which is
what makes slavery a horrible injustice
parents do have natural responsibilities
to their children which is why nearly
all societies in history including our
own legally require parents to care for
their children or else find somebody
else who will
the only question
is whether that responsibility should
begin at the moment when the child comes
into being at conception or at some
arbitrary point thereafter
pro-abortion people
favor the arbitrary point
in favoring the arbitrary point they
reject the personhood of children before
before the point they've decided
and uh arbitrarily rejecting a human
being's personhood so as to to deprive
that person of basic human rights
and of their dignity is exactly what
happened with slavery
so
bell is right to make the slavery
comparison he just forgot that in this
analogy
he's on the side of the slave owners
the video ends with men being encouraged
to celebrate abortion birth control and
bodily autonomy lumping all these things
together in one category
you may recall that the left used to
passionately deny that abortion is used
as birth control
and now they seem to have dropped the
act entirely
and now that now he's putting them
together it's the same thing
the relative honesty is at least one
positive thing in this video we can say
but it's not enough to save it and w
kamal bell from being today
cancelled well before you go uh hit the
subscribe button and ring the bell and
while you're at it if you want to go
watch or listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated